Personality disorders are maladaptive and inflexible patterns of cognition,
emotion and behavior. And they generally develop in late childhood or
adolescence and continue into adulthood. Now there are three distinct clusters
of personality disorders. There's odd and eccentric personality disorders.
There's dramatic and emotional personality disorders. And anxious fearful
personality disorders. Now we're going to examine the first two in more detail.
Let's first start by looking at the odd and eccentric personality disorders.
First we have schizoid personality disorder. We see that people with this do
not want to be close in any of their relationships. They're reclusive,
emotionally aloof, and humorless. And they also want to live solitary lives,
therefore we see them engage in solitary activities. They have no interest in
sex, they don't have close friends. And they don't seem to react to praise or
criticism from others. Another odd-eccentric diagnosis is schizotypal
personality disorder. Here, we see these individuals being isolated and
asocial, but we also see they have odd thoughts, perceptual distortions and
beliefs. And we may see that these people dressed, act, or appear in peculiar
or eccentric ways. And finally let's look at paranoid personality disorder.
People with paranoid personality disorder are extremely suspicious and
mistrustful of other people in ways that are unwarranted and not adaptive. They
may often test the loyalty of their friends and lovers. Because they believe
others are trying to harm them. People with paranoid personality disorder may
be regularly suspicious of their spouses' faithfulness even if there's no
evidence that the spouse has been unfaithful. But remember, these are extremes
of personality. So questioning the faithfulness of a significant other doesn't
necessarily mean you have a personality disorder. Remember, you would have to
be extremely paranoid to the point of it interfering with your day life, to
consider this a personality disorder.